[MUSIC PLAYING]
STACEY SASAKI: All right,
so "New York Times"
best-selling author
and co-creator
of The Whole30 Program, Melissa
has helped millions of people
achieve their weight
loss and health goals.
And we're really excited to
have her here today to talk hot
on the heels of her
latest book release,
"Food Freedom Forever, Letting
Go of Bad Habits, Guilt,
and Anxiety Around Food,"
only released yesterday, so we
are right at the cusp of that.
And we're excited
to have her here
to talk to us about what that's
all about, what The Whole30 is,
and answer all our
tough questions.
So please join me in welcoming
Melissa to Talks at Google.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
STACEY SASAKI: So
it's a pleasure
to have you here today, Melissa.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Thank
you, I'm really excited.
STACEY SASAKI: I'm
very excited too.
As a person who's very
interested in all the latest
food crazes exercise
crazes, as most of us are,
it's really great
to have you here
so you can navigate
things for us
and tell us about
yours and all of that.
MELISSA HARTWIG: I'm excited.
STACEY SASAKI: Perfect.
I mean, a lot of these people
already know about the Whole30.
It's a very well-known
program and pretty amazing.
But tell us a little about
it, just to get us going.
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Sure, so you can
think about the Whole30
pushing the reset button
with your health, your
habits, and your relationship
with food.
So for 30 days,
you'll eliminate foods
that the scientific literature
and our clinical experience
have shown to be really commonly
problematic to varying degrees
across a broad range of people.
So you pull that stuff out
completely for 30 days.
And you're going
to evaluate what
changes-- energy, sleep,
digestion, mood, skin,
athletic performance, recovery,
cravings, any kind of symptoms,
migraines, asthma,
allergies, all of this stuff.
You're going to see what
happens in the absence of some
of these potentially
problematic triggers.
At the end of the
30 days, you then
put those food back
in very carefully
and systematically,
one at a time,
like a scientific experiment.
And you pay attention
to what changes.
So does your
digestion get worse?
Does your skin break out?
Does that shoulder
pain come back?
It allows you to figure out how
food impacts you individually
because there's no
one-size-fits-all.
And it lets you create
the perfect diet
for you going forward.
STACEY SASAKI: Who
is the Whole30 for?
Is it for anyone?
Is it for kids?
Anyone can do this?
MELISSA HARTWIG: I think
everyone in the whole world
should do the Whole30.
But that's just me.
We have a lot of
medical doctors who
are using our program
with their patients
and seeing amazing results
with things like high blood
pressure, high cholesterol,
type 2 diabetes,
autoimmune conditions.
But you don't have to be sick
to benefit from the Whole30.
So if you're just looking
for improved energy,
managing your cravings,
reducing digestive distress,
or weight loss, even
though that's not
the main focus of our program,
the Whole30 is for you.
STACEY SASAKI: OK, and so tell
us a little bit more about what
we can have on the Whole30 so
we don't go into that what we
can't.
MELISSA HARTWIG: I like that.
I always like
starting with the cans
because the list of
no's can be a little
intimidating on the Whole30.
So let's start with
what you will be eating.
And I'm going to paint
a really good picture.
So meat, seafood, and
eggs, ideally naturally
raised and fed.
But you can have animal protein.
And we encourage a moderate
portion with every meal.
So it's certainly
not meat, meat, meat.
It's not a carnivorous plan.
It's actually really
moderate portions.
You're eating lot and lots of
plants, so lots of vegetables,
fresh fruit.
We're not afraid of things
like potatoes, sweet potatoes,
or fruit as a whole,
natural, nutrient-dense food.
You're eating good healthy fats,
so things like avocado, olives,
olive oil, duck fat,
ghee, coconut oil,
and coconut products.
And then you're doing
herbs and spices.
And people who do
Whole30 recipes,
like those who guest post on our
Whole30 recipes Instagram feed,
get incredibly creative
with these really hearty,
nourishing Whole30 meals.
STACEY SASAKI: So if I wanted
the super paleo double fudge
whatever, as long as
the ingredients are
like fake fudge, can I eat that?
MELISSA HARTWIG: Oh, you're
setting me up now, aren't you?
So there is a rule
in the Whole30 that
says you are not allowed to
recreate baked goods, treats,
desserts, junk foods
with technically
compliant ingredients.
So there is a way to
make Whole30 compliant
pancakes or muffins or cookies.
But remember, the Whole30 is
about changing your health,
but also your habits and
your emotional relationship
with food.
And these comfort foods are what
make us feel so out of control.
We start eating.
And we can't stop eating them.
So if you're trying
to change your habits
and your relationship with food,
and you eat pancakes, muffins,
and cookies, and then
you do the Whole30
and you continue to eat
pancakes, muffins, and cookies,
how much are those
things going to change?
So we do have a rule
that says that's a no-no.
STACEY SASAKI: So you
said we can have fruit.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Right.
STACEY SASAKI: I have
this thing about fruit.
I have a friend who says no
one ever got fat off of fruit,
so you're fine.
But if you saw my
fruit mound I have
morning and every
afternoon working here,
you'd be like, hmmm.
I think I'm the only person
who might be able to do it.
Is that good as a
dessert replacement?
MELISSA HARTWIG: So
again, we don't generally
encourage dessert replacements,
because even if it's
a healthier choice,
what we want to do
is get you out of
the habit of dessert.
I don't want you
to feel like you
have to have something
sweet before the meal can
feel complete.
So if you want dessert
occasionally, great, eat it.
That's fantastic.
But I don't want you to
feel like it's necessary.
I'm not afraid of eating fruit.
But what I don't want
you to do is use fruit
to satisfy your sugar cravings.
So if every day at
3 o'clock, you're
used to having a Snickers bar,
and then you do the Whole30,
and every day at 3
o'clock, you're like,
OK, well, I can't
do a Snickers bar,
so I'm going to do a Lara Bar,
it's a better food choice,
but you're still
feeding your brain
the sugar that it's throwing
a temper tantrum for.
So you're not actually changing
anything in that pattern.
So it's not just about
what you're eating.
It's about why you're
eating it and some
of the emotional reasons
behind that relationship
with that particular food.
STACEY SASAKI: So how
does the Whole30 really
help you get at those
emotional relationships?
You just don't eat if you're
having those sugar cravings?
MELISSA HARTWIG: Yeah.
STACEY SASAKI: Yeah?
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Well, I mean, no.
STACEY SASAKI: Dont eat it.
MELISSA HARTWIG: A lot of
these traditional diets
just ask you to white knuckle
your way through them.
Right?
They don't provide
a lot of rationale.
They don't provide support.
They don't provide
a big community.
They're not giving
you alternatives
to not eating the cookie
at 9 o'clock at night.
So all you're
doing is willpower,
white knuckling
your way through it,
thinking about what you're
going to eat on Day 31,
the carbopalooza that
you're going to have, right?
What we do on the Whole30
is provide alternatives.
So because we limit
those comfort foods
that you would
normally reach for,
and because we've got really
strong recommendations
against-- like, OK,
well, yes, they're
just homemade plantain chips.
But if you feel like you're not
in control when you eat them,
is that really what you
want for your Whole30?
We force people to find other
ways to comfort themselves,
to reward themselves, to
self-soothe, to show love
with other people
in their lives so
that at the end of the
program, you actually
have some new habits
to fall back on,
not just the same habits
with different foods.
STACEY SASAKI:
What kind of things
can we use besides
food to self-soothe?
It's hard, right?
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Yeah, it's funny.
It is tough.
But I said on
Instagram the other day
and so many people
responded to it,
like, you're not
looking for a cookie.
You're looking for a connection.
And so often what
I find is people
who rely on food for
those emotional--
to fill that emotional hole.
You're not going to
find that at the bottom
of a bag of potato chips.
And we all know this.
But we don't know
what else to do.
And because the food is
super normally stimulating,
incredibly rewarding, and
it's got low satiety factors,
we overconsume.
And then we feel even
worse about ourselves.
And then we say we're not
going to do that again,
except that we do because we
don't know what else to do.
And I find the
interpersonal connection
to be so key in relieving
anxiety and stress
and having that motivation
and that accountability
and giving and receiving love.
So I think the next time you
find yourself in that situation
where you're reaching for food
that you don't really want,
but you don't know what else to
do, reach out to someone else
instead.
Go see a friend.
Text message, phone call, make
it as personal as you can.
And I really would
find it hard to believe
that that didn't
relieve or fill you up
with what you were looking for.
STACEY SASAKI: Great.
And you have a whole
Whole30 community too
for people to reach out to.
What's that like?
MELISSA HARTWIG: The
Whole30 community
is incredibly robust,
fiercely loyal,
and I think one of the
most positive and welcoming
communities online.
We've got almost two million
photos hashtagged #Whole30
on Instagram right now.
I mean, it is the thriving.
And people are connecting
with each other.
So if you don't have someone
at home or in your community
that you're doing the Whole30
with, you can come to my house.
And we'll make sure that you
stay motivated and accountable.
We'll answer your questions.
We'll provide you with support.
I have a lot of people
who will Snapchat me
and say, I really
want a cookie today.
I don't know what else to do.
And sometimes, all they
need is someone to say,
you're not going out like that.
And they're OK.
And they keep going.
So this is how connected
I am to our community,
and my entire team.
So yeah, I really am super
proud of our Whole30ers.
STACEY SASAKI: That's great.
That's really great.
So the person who like, I'm
going to have a cookie today.
I can't resist.
They actually do it on
the Whole30 program.
Then what happens?
MELISSA HARTWIG: So
ideally, with the Whole30,
if you go off-plan,
you start over.
And it's not because we're
trying to be like a hazing,
or like the boot camp of
paleo, because the basis,
the foundation of the Whole30
is an elimination diet.
You are eliminating these
foods to see whether or not
they work for you.
And the analogy I like to
use is, say you have 10 cats,
and you want to know if
you're allergic to cats.
So you get rid of
nine of your cats.
Do you feel better?
Maybe, but you still have a cat.
How are you supposed
to know whether or not
cats impact you if you've
still got one hanging out?
So you want to know if
you're allergic to cats.
You have 10 cats.
You give up all 10 of your cats.
But Saturday morning, you kick
you heels up with the cat.
Or Friday night,
you're like, I'm
just going to have
one little cat.
Right?
Whether that's pizza
or a beer or whatever
it is you're thinking
about, you can't accurately
evaluate how these
foods are impacting you
if you're including them even
a little bit in the plan.
So it's 100%
elimination for 30 days.
Think of it like a
scientific experiment.
And if you do go
off-plan, I really
encourage people to start over,
both for the physiological
reasons, but also,
because I want
you to honor the commitment that
you made to yourself, 30 days.
STACEY SASAKI: So you mentioned,
obviously, paleo in there.
Is the Whole30 a paleo diet?
Are there differences?
What's the--
MELISSA HARTWIG: There are
significant differences.
It's based on the general
framework of the paleo diet
because the research
behind the foods that
are eliminated on the paleo
diet are pretty solid.
Again, we're not saying
these foods are good or bad.
We're not saying these foods
are healthy or less healthy
for you.
We're saying they're
very commonly
problematic to varying degrees.
And I don't know how they
work for you until you
do the Whole30 and
do this experiment
and figure it out for yourself.
So the foods that you eliminate
on the Whole30 like grains,
legumes, and dairy
are all foods that
are also off-limits with
the paleo-style diet.
But we do include
potatoes in the Whole30
because they're a real
nutrient-dense food.
And lots of paleo people
say potatoes don't count.
You're not allowed to
do those egg and banana
pancakes that I talked
about and some of the paleo
treats and desserts
that are out there.
So there are some differences.
Our program is for a
very specific purpose.
STACEY SASAKI: And so
when we're talking about,
we do this Whole30.
We make it.
Thank, god.
What happens next?
It's scary.
MELISSA HARTWIG:
It can be scary.
And that's really what "Food
Freedom Forever" is about
is people did the Whole30.
We've had millions
of people do it.
And they have amazing success.
And they feel like they
really changed their habits.
And it's like the first thing
that's really worked for them.
And then they're
like, OK, now what?
Because I don't want to go back
to the way that I was eating,
but I don't know
how to not do that,
especially in the
face of a holiday,
a vacation, a stressful event.
So that's really what
"Food Freedom Forever"
is about is it's
the three-step plan
to help people get past that
short-term dietary intervention
and turn what they've
learned into a lifetime
of healthy habits.
STACEY SASAKI: So it
stems from the terror
that people feel
when they're like,
oh, I have to go back
into the real world
now, eat some real food.
What's that going to look like?
I mean, maybe that's excitement.
But I think for a lot of
people, it's also terror.
MELISSA HARTWIG: We
call it frexcited.
It's frightened and
excited at the same time.
Right?
I mean, you're excited to
get back to some of the foods
that you really love and
see how they work for you.
But at the same time, you
feel so good that you just
don't want to mess it up.
And you're afraid that if you
do let some of these foods
back in, it's going to send
you down this slippery slide
of feeling out of control again.
And I've provided a lot of
guidance over the years about
what to do, but never in a
really clear step-by- step
do this, do that format.
So this came from my community
saying, I need more help.
I need more help in
life after the Whole30.
STACEY SASAKI: You
mentioned that carbopalooza
that could happen immediately
following your Whole30.
Day 31, yay, I can
have all the pasta.
But I don't think
that's how it works.
So tell us about
the reintroduction.
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Yeah, we did a survey.
I think we had more than
5,000 Whole30ers respond.
And of those people
who finished a Whole30
and said that at the
beginning of their program,
they thought they
were going to want
to eat all the things on Day
31, 75% of them at the end
said, I actually didn't want to.
I felt so different.
And things had changed so
much-- my tastes had changed--
that I didn't want to do that.
But in between the
Whole30 and your food
freedom comes this
reintroduction period.
Remember, you eliminate, and
then you bring them back in.
So we've got both a 10-day
fast track reintroduction
outlined in the "Whole30" book.
And then we've got
this slow roll option
for people who maybe don't
want to bring everything
back in within 10 days.
But the reintroduction is
the money of the program.
This is where you learn
how these foods impact you
and where you learn
how much and how often
and what kinds of foods you
can bring back into your life
so that it's delicious and
healthy and feels sustainable,
but in a way that's not
going to mess you up
in terms of how awesome
you want to look and feel.
STACEY SASAKI: Great.
So if we're slowly reintroducing
things, what does it look like?
Say, OK, today is dairy day.
Do I go and eat yogurt
all day and top if off
with a dab of milk and
then have a brick of cheese
with ice cream?
MELISSA HARTWIG: Maybe
not a brick of cheese.
STACEY SASAKI: No?
Oh, OK.
MELISSA HARTWIG: But basically,
what you want to do-- again,
think of it like a
scientific experiment.
Dairy is going to be
your experimental factor.
And the Whole30 is your control.
So your entire diet
for the whole day
is going to be Whole30.
The only thing you're
adding back in is dairy.
So you would do your
typical Whole30 breakfast.
Maybe it's some poached eggs,
maybe a little bit of avocado
and a veggie medley
and some mixed berries.
But you're going to sprinkle
some cheese on your eggs.
So you're going to
add the dairy back
in a way that allows you
to evaluate just the dairy
component alone.
And then you're going to go back
to the Whole30 for two or three
days and see what happens
in terms of the reaction
because sometimes the
reaction can take a day
or so to manifest, depending
on how sensitive you are.
STACEY SASAKI: You don't
want to overdo it, but slowly
bring it in and test it out.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Yeah, and
you have to do enough of it
to really see.
So if you just put a drop
of milk in your coffee,
what are the chances
that you're really
going to notice an impact?
So you want to do some
cream in your coffee,
some cheese on your omelet,
maybe a side of yogurt
with your lunch, and then
at dinner, some other form
of dairy that you really like.
What you don't want to
do is do a giant bowl
of ice cream that also has
cookie dough, that also
is topped with chocolate syrup
because then you're not going
to know what's impacting
you, the dairy or the gluten
or the massive sugar bomb.
STACEY SASAKI: OK.
So what about people
who-- is there
some way to do this if you
don't want to go strict Whole30?
They're pretty
strict guidelines.
I think that they
make a lot of fans.
And it's really
great to find out.
But some people are like, so
if I said I want to do this,
but I don't care how
alcohol affects me.
I don't care if it
makes me bloated.
makes my skin break out.
I want to try to get rid
of all the other things,
bring it all in.
Can I still do a
Whole30ish program?
Or is it a no-no?
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Doing the Whole30
is a little like being pregnant.
You either are, or you're not.
There is no kind of, right?
So if you're going
to do the program,
the way I describe
it is if you're
going to come play my game,
you need to play by my rules.
And all I'm asking
for is 30 days.
And all I'm asking is for you
to trust me for one month.
And I've got seven years
of experience backing up
my recommendations.
But the Whole30 is
not for everyone.
So if you're vegan,
for example, you
can't do the Whole30 as written
because we are basically
excluding all of your
plant-based protein sources.
And the rules are rigid.
And it's a lot to imagine
giving up at once.
It can be a very
emotional journey.
So in "Food Freedom
Forever," I have
outlined several different
resets that you can do,
not all of which are as
intense as the Whole30,
but all of which will
get you to the place
where you know how
food impacts you,
and you're in a better balance
in terms of your blood sugar
regulation, hormonal balance,
digestion, and immune system.
So the Whole30 isn't
the price of admission
for "Food "Freedom,"
but I will strongly
encourage everyone to do it.
And I do several
times in the book.
STACEY SASAKI: Awesome.
So if you're looking
to do something,
your book will give you a few
different options for things.
Yeah, I did have the
question as well is,
if I'm a vegetarian,
vegan, or I can't have soy,
so I can't have tofu,
which I would usually
have on the Whole30 strictly.
But you definitely
give people options.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Yeah,
there is a full vegan
reset outlined here.
And you're eliminating the most
commonly problematic protein
sources, again, according
to the literature.
And in all of the resets,
you're pulling out alcohol.
Like, come on, guys.
You're going to pull
out alcohol for 30 days.
Right?
In all of the resets, you're
eliminating added sugar
and some of those processed
food with no breaks,
and some of those sweet treats
and desserts and baked goods.
All of the resets,
that's the very baseline
of the elimination.
There's a basic reset
outlined in here
that's as bare
bones as possible.
But what I say in the book,
with all sorts of tough love--
emphasis on the love--
is if you're not
willing to do at
least this, you're
not ready for this
program right now.
STACEY SASAKI: That's fair.
That's fair.
I like the tough
love in the book.
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Heavy on the love.
STACEY SASAKI: Yes,
of course, of course.
But it's very real.
You give it us straight.
So I very much appreciate that.
Have you ever had anybody go
through the Whole30 program
and do their whole
reintroduction, ad
they're just like, I don't
notice anything different.
I don't notice any of my
allergies flare up or whatever.
I still had headaches
the whole time.
Is there anything like that?
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Sometimes the Whole30
doesn't work super well
for absolutely everybody.
For some people, food may
not be your biggest issue.
If you've already been eating
really squeaky clean or close
to Whole30ish and you're
already pretty healthy,
maybe there's something
else going on.
Maybe it's because you're only
sleeping five hours a night,
or you're doing two-a-day
CrossFit sessions
and not recovering actively.
So food might not be
your biggest issue.
The Whole30 also
can't fix everything.
So if you've got this
underlying, undiagnosed gut
infection or you've got
an autoimmune condition
that you've been living with
and it's been progressing
for the last 20
years, the Whole30
might give you a good start
towards feeling better.
But you may need to work with
a functional medicine doctor
to make sure that you're
getting the treatment that's
applicable for you.
Yeah.
STACEY SASAKI: So yeah,
that makes a lot of sense.
The other thing that I
think can be problematic
is the whole thing around
social networks, family.
How do you navigate that?
I know going to my
mom's and saying,
oh, I'm not eating
gluten or dairy.
I'm not having alcohol.
I'm not-- she'll just be
like, well, don't come home.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Right.
STACEY SASAKI: So what do we do?
MELISSA HARTWIG: So
not what you just said.
STACEY SASAKI: OK.
MELISSA HARTWIG: That's
a terrible way to do it.
I actually have three chapters
in "Food Freedom Forever"
about how to talk to friends,
family, and coworkers
about food, three chapters.
Not overkill because talking to
friends and family about food
is third only to
religion and politics
in terms of how
divisive it can be.
You started talking about
food and changing your diet,
and immediately,
people get judgmental.
They get defensive like you
don't have to do anything.
You can just roll up to the
table with your Whole30 meal
and the entire table
all of a sudden
feels like it's being attacked.
So what I like to
say is A, don't have
the conversation over food.
Right?
Have it away from food and
ideally, ahead of time.
B, you always want
to be lead with all
of the positive things.
And you want to make the
conversation as personal
as is appropriate for
your relationship.
So if you're talking to
your mom, and you say,
I hear the Whole30 is
really good for cravings,
that's not going to particularly
bring you close together.
If you say, Mom, you sent me
home with your chocolate chip
cookies the other day.
And I said I was only
going to eat one.
And I ended up eating five.
And it makes me feel
really bad about myself
that I can't control
what I'm eating.
So I'm going to do this
experiment for 30 days
where I try to break
my reliance on sugar
and change my cravings.
It means I won't be able
to eat your cookies.
But it's only for a month.
And when I get done, I'll
be able to really enjoy
them the way you want me to.
Right?
That's a totally
different conversation.
So make it personal.
And then make it relatable.
So if your mom is
mostly sedentary,
you saying, I'm going
to do the Whole30
and I'm hoping to cut my
5K time by three minutes,
not relatable.
If you know your
mom also suffers
from cravings or sleep or
energy issues, bond with her
on that level.
Man, every day at 2 o'clock,
my head's on my desk,
and I feel like I need
caffeine and chocolate.
You know what I mean?
Oh, yeah, me too.
I'm going to do this
Whole30 because it's really
meant to reset
your energy levels
and give you that awake feeling
without needing extra caffeine.
And now, she's listening.
So those are my best tips.
STACEY SASAKI: Is that
where you also say,
maybe you should do it with me?
Or how does that work?
MELISSA HARTWIG: Tread very
carefully with that, you guys.
The phrase I like to use
is lead by quiet example.
You can ask for her support.
Mom, will you
support me in this?
If I'm having a tough
day, can I call you
and have you tell me what
a good job I'm doing?
But you don't want to ever push
someone into trying to do it.
Right?
Instead, just lead
by quiet example.
Look awesome.
Feel awesome.
Talk about your results,
your non-scale victories.
Hey, Mom, I saw a plate of
cookies at the office today,
and I wasn't even tempted.
I feel so good.
What a great sign that is.
And then just sit back
because at some point,
they will say, what
have you been doing.
Tell me a little more about it.
And maybe it will take
them a while to get there,
but you just do you.
STACEY SASAKI: Talk to
me a little bit more
about non-scale
victories because I
think our society is really
obsessed with that number that
appears whenever you get on it.
How do you get away from that?
What are the things
to celebrate?
I think that's a good example.
Walking away from the
cookies, I think, Is huge.
MELISSA HARTWIG: It's huge.
And so one of the
other rules of the 30
is that you're not
allowed to step
on the scale for 30 days,
which, for some, is the hardest
rule of them all.
But it is not a
weight loss program.
And it is not about weight.
I think we all need
a break from letting
this $20 hunk of plastic
hold our self-esteem
and self-confidence hostage.
So we focus on what we
call non-scale victories.
And in Whole30 lingo,
it's hashtag #NSV.
And what people will
do is look for things
like-- maybe some of
them are physical.
Maybe it's oh, I'm
down about belt loop.
Or my wedding ring now fits.
It was too small,
and now it fits.
I love hearing that.
Maybe it's a craving thing,
like I didn't need the cookie.
I was able to walk
past the cookie.
Or I didn't need the candy bar.
Or I finally feel like
I'm in control of food.
Maybe it's digestive.
Maybe it's skin glowing
and clearing up.
We hear a lot of that.
Maybe it's I went to my
doctor and my blood sugar
is better managed.
Or I'm no longer
type 2 diabetic.
But there is this huge list
of non-scale victory in a PDF
we give you on
the Whole30 sheet.
And it's like, check
them off, people,
because the more you can
check off, the more motivated
you will be to continue.
STACEY SASAKI: Totally.
And so even after the
Whole30, is it still no scale?
Are you anti-scale?
MELISSA HARTWIG: I'm anti-scale
if getting on that number
actually matters.
If you with trepidation
close your eyes
and cross your fingers before
you step on that scale,
maybe it's better to
get off the scale.
I have a scale at my house.
I use it to weigh my suitcases--
68 pounds for this trip, 68--
or to weight my son.
And occasionally, I'll step
on and just kind of see
where I am.
But it doesn't mean anything.
So I am OK with
weighing yourself
before and after because
for some people, obviously,
I understand weight loss is a
big goal for a lot of people.
And I don't want to
minimize how amazing it
is if you can eat to satiety
and not count calories and still
lose weight.
Awesome.
But if that number is going to
ruin your day or make your day,
maybe you should examine your
relationship with the scale.
STACEY SASAKI: Totally fair.
Totally fair.
In terms of either
technologies-- we're Google.
We care about are there things
that you are on board with?
Again, things that are
helpful, [INAUDIBLE]
fitness trackers, wearables,
the posture coach, the fork
that you mentioned in your book.
MELISSA HARTWIG: The happy fork.
Yeah, I don't know
about the happy fork.
It vibrates to let you know
if you're eating too quickly.
But it's like 80 bucks.
So I'm like, maybe
you could just
stop eating like
you're in prison.
STACEY SASAKI: That's one
of my favorite quotes.
MELISSA HARTWIG: But i
do like the wearables.
If you're the kind of
person who is motivated
by seeing your
results, then things
that can improve on the
Whole30 that you'll notice
is naturally, your steps will go
up because you'll feel better,
and you'll want
to be more active,
and you'll park further away.
And you won't sweat
taking the stairs.
So that's cool.
Your sleep quality, being
able to track your sleep,
and whether you're
falling asleep easier,
sleeping longer, getting
more restful sleep,
awesome non-scale
victory on the Whole30.
So if you can find some
of those little ways
to not only track your
progress, but tie it to wow,
it's stuff that you wouldn't
necessarily, I guess,
link back to your diet.
Taking more steps?
But if you see a change in that,
it can be really motivating.
STACEY SASAKI: Yeah.
I have one last question
for you before I open it
up to everybody, who's probably
dying to ask you things.
They're like, stop talking.
But I'm curious about just
changing the whole relationship
about good and bad foods.
And how do you even
get to that thought
because I think it's hard.
It's very hard for people to
know that it's not necessarily
this is good for you,
this is bad for you,
or you're a good
person or a bad person.
And you talk a lot about
the language of food.
How do we change that?
MELISSA HARTWIG: It's
really important.
I think the language
of food is often
what's holding us hostage
in our relationship.
And what I really
emphasize in the Whole30
and also in "Food Freedom"
is these foods that you're
eliminating, it's not
because they're bad.
There's no good or bad food.
You're pulling them out
and putting them back
in because they're unknown.
That's it.
You just want to figure
out how they work for you.
And you are not good or
bad based on the food
that you put on your plate.
And I think once we can get
past the idea of our self-worth
being tied to what
our body weight is,
or what size jeans we
fit into, or whether we
are the exerciser or
the healthy person,
I think it makes
a huge difference
in letting food be
more fun and easy
and playful and
rewarding and joyful.
I'm not trying to
take any of that away.
So I write a lot about the
idea of a growth mindset
and changing your language.
It's a real shift, a re-frame,
from the diet culture
we've had for the
last 20 years, where
it was all about deprivation
and restriction and willpower
and good foods and bad foods.
And I want to change
all of that paradigm.
STACEY SASAKI: The
learning to think about it
in a different way than we
do, it just seems so hard.
But I think that you give a
lot of great tips in the book.
I won't spoil them all.
But yeah, I think
it's a challenge
to be solved, related to
the goods and the bads.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Yeah, but
the more you practice that--
and I talk about things
like leaving post-it notes
around your house.
It sounds kind of
silly, but the more
you can reinforce
the ideas behind,
I'm a healthy person
with healthy habits.
And I'm living a
healthy lifestyle.
And this is a
scientific experiment.
It's an experiment.
It's not a diet.
And the more you can re-frame--
and I really emphasize that
over and over again-- I
think the better chance
you have of that
actually sticking.
And changing your foods and
changing your relationship
with foods and
feeling like you're
building new healthy habits will
only serve to reinforce that.
STACEY SASAKI: I love that.
That's great.
All right, guys.
Open it up.
We have one right there.
Yeah, sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
This was really interesting.
And as someone who's generally
a health-focused eater,
but also hasn't
ever really dieted,
I was wondering if you could
elaborate a little bit more
on your last point there,
about the idea of after you're
done with the
Whole30, not thinking
about foods as good and bad.
I don't know too much
about the Whole30.
But I've seen peers or
people on my Facebook
or whatever doing it.
And to me, it always
kind of worries me,
the idea of saying you
can't have these things.
And it seems a little bit sad
if after the Whole30 would end,
then you still feel like,
I can't have the cookies.
I can't have--
even if you end up
being OK with dairy and eggs.
And eating disorders are also
a thing that happens too.
So, I guess, what's your
perspective on after people
finish the Whole30
and they figure out
what they can and can't have,
then transitioning to be like,
OK, now we're going to
bake pumpkin cookies.
And I'm going to have one.
And that's OK.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Yeah, that's
a really great question.
And that all-or-nothing
is the diet mentality.
Right?
I'm either on this diet
and I'm white knuckling
my way through it, or I'm
face first in a box of donuts.
And so I start from
the very beginning,
from your elimination period
with the Whole30 saying,
you're not eliminating these
foods because they're bad.
They're just unknown.
And you just want to figure
out how they work for you.
And it's not the Whole365.
It's the Whole30.
So it's a 30-day, scientific
elimination period.
And then after that, I want you
to live in your food freedom.
I want you to figure out what
does work for you and what
doesn't.
In fact, the goal I propose in
"Food Freedom Forever" is this.
I want your diet to be as
broad an expansive as possible,
while still looking
and feeling as awesome
as you want to look and feel.
And you get to draw that line.
I'm not drawing it for you.
So I have figured out
that I can get away
with a couple
glasses of wine here
and there, some Justin's
Peanut Butter Cups here
and there, my mom's
chocolate chip walnut cake.
And I still look
just as awesome.
And I still feel
So guess what?
I do because it makes
my life so delicious
and healthy and rewarding
and happy, like emotionally
healthy.
So I want you to do that.
And if you start
from the beginning
not thinking about
these foods as bad
and that's why you're
eliminating them,
then you shouldn't
feel the same guilt
when you bring them back in.
I don't want you to feel guilty
reintroducing these foods.
You may make the wrong
choice sometimes.
I may overdo it on the wine or
my mom's chocolate chip walnut
cake.
And I'm like, wow, that
was a poor decision.
I don't feel as good.
And my energy is down.
My mood is down.
OK, so I learned from that,
and I apply it the next time
that situation comes up.
But I encourage everyone
to find that line.
How much can you
get away with so
that your life is amazing and
rewarding and delicious and
satisfying and full of your
family and friend traditions
while still maintaining
all of the health
benefits you want to maintain?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Yeah, thanks.
STACEY SASAKI: Just to follow
up on that, what if you
do you overdo it and
just completely fall off
after you've done your Whole30?
MELISSA HARTWIG:
So one of the steps
in "Food Freedom Forever,"
so it's you do your reset.
You live your food freedom.
And you acknowledge that
your habits have slipped.
So I have built
right into the plan
that you will fall
off the wagon.
Isn't that relieving?
Because all of these
diets are like,
oh, you're going to
do our 21-day detox,
and then you'll never, ever
have to diet ever again.
Everything's going to
be magically changed.
And that's completely
unrealistic,
even for a program as
good as the Whole30.
And it's good in
changing people's habits.
Eventually, you fall
back into old ruts.
You're trying to
overwrite decades
of less healthy behaviors
and associations
and emotional
relationships with food.
You're not going to
fix that in 30 days.
So if that happens, you just
come back to your reset,
whether it's a full Whole30,
or maybe a Whole3 or a Whole7.
However long you need
to feel back in control
and to get that energy and
sleep and mood and digestion
rocking again, cool.
You know it works.
You know how to do it.
You know it's going to
make you feel amazing.
And then as soon as
you're done, as soon
as you're able, as
soon as possible,
because I want you to get right
back to your food freedom,
you're back to living in your
normal healthy balance again.
It's simple.
And you continue that cycle
literally in perpetuity
until, ideally, you never need
another Whole30 ever again.
I'll probably never do
a full 30 ever again.
STACEY SASAKI: Really?
MELISSA HARTWIG:
No, I don't need it.
STACEY SASAKI: Does it
get easier each time?
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Of course it does.
It gets easier.
You learn more.
You become more selective
about what's worth it for you.
You identify foods that
maybe don't work for you,
but it's really nuanced.
Oh, I didn't notice this
after my first Whole30.
But by my third, don't think
this is worth it anymore.
Yeah, it gets easier.
And it just becomes what you do.
You no longer even
have to think about.
STACEY SASAKI: Great.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's Brooke.
Thanks so much for coming.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Hi, Brooke.
AUDIENCE: I'm on Day 10
of Whole30 round four.
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Yay, welcome back.
AUDIENCE: I've done it.
This is my fourth time.
And I started a year ago.
And I swear to god, it
completely changed my life.
So if anyone's doubting, you
absolutely have to try it.
I don't do the gluten or the
dairy or alcohol anymore.
And it has completely
changed my life.
So thank you.
So with all these resets
and having over the course
of a year decided to
eliminate those things,
the one thing that
does change and does
keep me going back to
Whole30 is the fact
that the sugar thing sneaks in.
So if it's like a
fucking-- sorry.
I love gummies.
And I love almond milk ice
cream and stuff like that.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Sure, yeah.
AUDIENCE: But I noticed that
actually, interestingly enough,
I lost a lot of weight
at the beginning.
And then eliminating all the
foods that affect me poorly,
my weight's actually
gone back up.
I'm wondering what maybe the
scientific reason for that is,
and if it is the sugar.
I mean, that would make sense.
But I've heard also
before, perhaps,
that your body level sets and
kind of recalibrates after you
eliminate all these things.
I was just wondering
if you could
speak to that a little bit.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Yeah,
there's a million questions
I would have to ask you.
So do you have a history of
yo-yo dieting, where you lose,
then gain.
AUDIENCE: Kind of, yeah.
MELISSA HARTWIG:
How long are you
sleeping every single night?
What are you doing for exercise?
Is it high intensity stuff?
Are you adequately
recovering from that?
What does your life
stress look like?
We would sit down and have a
serious therapy session for me
to talk about-- maybe
it's the food, maybe.
A food journal can be very
helpful in this situation
because I might say to
you, how are you getting
after your Whole30, Brooke.
And you're like, I'm
doing pretty well.
And then if I made you write
down every single thing
like that, not weighing or
measuring, just write it down,
you're like, oh, wow, that Luna
Bar and almond milk ice cream's
coming back a
couple times a week.
And we were having a
conversation before about
the bags of the plantain chips.
You think they're healthy.
If you hoover one of those,
it is like 560 calories.
And it's not that
calories don't count.
Right?
So it's basically like a
mini-meal all unto itself.
So maybe a food journal.
Maybe it's the food.
But maybe food isn't your
biggest issue anymore.
And maybe it's time to look
at things like caffeine
consumption and
sleep, or what you're
doing for training and
recovery, or what's
going on with your life stress.
I know a lot of people
who go on vacation
and immediately,
they lose 10 pounds,
even though their eating
habits dramatically changed.
And I'm like, well, shocking.
You have no stress on vacation.
Everything's easy and simple.
So there's just so many
factors that play into that.
Consider keeping a journal
just for a few days
after your Whole30, just to see
if stuff is sneaking back in.
And then maybe consider going to
work with a functional medicine
doctor, doing some
very basic testing.
It could be an underlying,
undiagnosed gut infection,
for example.
Really common in
some of these cases.
So it could be a
number of things.
But it's not always food.
And I find when people
do multiple Whole30s,
they want to tie
everything back to food.
And food is a huge part of it.
But it's not the only part.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Yeah, you're welcome.
And good luck.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Awesome,
thanks for coming.
Two questions.
The first one is a simple one.
Just when you travel, how
do you prepare for that?
And what foods do
you personally have?
The second one is more like,
I'm curious on your journey
to actually write this book.
And I'd be interested
in this because I had
tons of dietary issues earlier.
And I was placed on
the low FODMAP diet.
It's just like
Whole30, but stricter.
And it was phenomenal.
It changed my life.
Now, I'm like very paleo
with a side of sugar.
And so just curious how
you got to this point.
Was it you hit some mark,
and then you were like, wow,
I need to change my life.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Oh, I did.
I'll answer the first
question first about travel.
So my bag on the way for
this book tour was 68 pounds.
And I'm pretty sure six
pounds of that were meat
sticks, like jerky sticks.
So I always pack a
ton of emergency food.
And I pack a really
healthy protein
because that's the hardest thing
to find when you're traveling.
It's easy to find fruit
and nuts and seeds.
But so I'm packing like
Epic bars and WildBars,
and DNX bars, and
the meat sticks.
Literally, if anyone
wants to try one,
I've got like seven
in my bag right now.
I do as much research
as I can ahead of time.
So when I land, I know where
the local health food store.
I know where the local
grocery store is.
I know a few good lunch options.
I've already looked at
the menu to make sure.
I can wing it anywhere
at this point.
But I still want to make it
as easy on myself as possible
so that when I get there,
I already have a plan.
And I'm not stuck
in rush hour traffic
after a really long
flight super hangry
with nowhere to go for food.
I make sure that my
hotel has a refrigerator
so I can stock up on a few
things at the grocery store.
So those are some tips
that make it easier.
I wrote an article called
"Business Travel 101"
on the whole30.com that
lays out my incredibly
anal retentive travel plan
because I travel so much.
And it's really
important to me to make
it as stress-free as possible.
As for my journey, I was not
always a really healthy person.
I'm actually a
recovering drug addict.
I've been clean for
almost 17 years.
And that--
[APPLAUSE]
Oh, thanks.
I always feel weird when
people clap for that.
I'm like, I got
myself messed up,
so I'm not sure you should
applaud me getting unmessed up.
But it is a big deal.
And I started in health
and exercise and nutrition
when I got out of
rehab because I
knew that I had to
change everything
about my life to stay clean.
I had to adopt
that growth mindset
and convince myself
that I wasn't
some degenerate, worthless loser
who couldn't change her life.
So I started exercising.
And I started eating healthier.
And I got some fitness
certifications,
and ran a CrossFit
gym for a while,
and did some
kettlebell coaching.
And that was really
where my path
started was through
my own transformation.
And so if you've
done the Whole30,
knowing this about
my background,
the rules kind of make sense.
The rigidity kind
of makes sense.
The steps and the
community makes sense
because it was all of the things
that I needed to get and stay
clean 17 years ago.
So yeah, there's
a chapter on that
here because if you looked at
me now, I think a lot of people
would say like, what do
you know about feeling out
of control with your food.
I've never been overweight.
That's not a struggle
or a battle I've fought.
But trust me when I say
I have fought my battles.
And drugs and food are not
that different in terms
of the impact they have on the
brain and cravings and reward
and your social interactions
and your self-confidence.
And so I do write about that.
Thanks.
STACEY SASAKI: To follow
up quickly on the food,
going out to eat, vacations,
that sort of thing--
I think one of the great things
about Google-- there's many--
is that we get a menu every day.
And we see all of the things
that are available to us.
And it gives you all
of the allergens.
But when you go to a
restaurant, you don't have that.
So people who are not in this
world, how do you navigate?
What do you say?
How do you go out for dinner?
MELISSA HARTWIG: Yeah,
this is totally my process.
The first thing I
do is go on Yelp.
And I do a search for American
New, or grass-fed burger,
or vegetarian breakfast
because for some reason,
the vegetarian breakfasts
tend to lead me
to the grass-fed, organic,
farm-to-table places.
I look at the menu.
If the menu looks
pretty doable--
I'm looking for simple
protein options.
So it's like a steak or grilled
fish or eggs or a burger,
like cool.
I look at the sides.
Do I have a bunch
of veggie choices.
Like great.
Occasionally, if I have to,
I'll call the restaurant
ahead of time and say, look.
I'm walking in like,
this is my stuff.
And I don't make a
big deal out of it.
I don't eat this, this,
or this right now.
Do you have options that
would accommodate me?
Or when I come in, can
I make a some requests?
I had a lamb burger at the
Breslin last night, so good.
But they don't do substitutions.
That's very helpful
to know up front.
So I walked in.
And I did no bun and no cheese.
And they did that.
But they wouldn't
substitute my salad
dressing for a
different dressing
because it was cream-based.
So I just asked for lemon and
a little bit of olive oil.
And they were cool with that.
But it's good to
know ahead of time.
So just do your
research ahead of time.
And then when you get
there, make your order
and be as matter of fact
and polite as possible.
The bigger a deal
you make about it,
the bigger a deal everyone
else is going to make.
So don't walk in there and be
like, oh, I know it's so weird.
And I'm going to be
your special person.
And I'm so sorry.
Like no, can I have this?
And can I not have the
bun and not have cheese?
And can you sub the fries?
I see you've got
broccoli in this dish.
Can I just get some broccoli
steamed on the side?
Thank you so much.
And then you tip
very generously.
STACEY SASAKI: I like it.
AUDIENCE: That was actually
one of my questions.
But the other question is,
how do you find the right time
to do this because I
always feel like I'm
oh, I can't this month.
I have two client events.
Or I can't next month,
it's Thanksgiving.
How do you find or prioritize
the right 30 days to start?
MELISSA HARTWIG: That's
a really great question.
So first of all,
you want to remember
that it's not just the 30 days.
It's 30 days plus
re-introduction.
So I see people sometimes
who are like, oh,
my day 31 is my trip to Italy.
And I'm like, oh,
you're really going
to have a hard time
reintroducing there.
And if you don't
reintroduce, you're
missing a lot of the
benefit of the program.
So ideally, you're
finding a 40-day block.
I want you to not do the Whole30
ideally over the holidays.
Right?
That's just asking for trouble.
Plus during the
holidays, you've got
a lot of these once-a-year,
really special family foods.
And I don't necessarily want
you to miss out on that.
So find a 40-day block where
you don't have an A level race,
or you're not getting
married that month,
or you don't have a once in a
lifetime vacation to Croatia.
But a client event is
not a good enough reason.
I want you to
figure out how to do
this in all of life's
circumstances-- bridal showers,
family dinners, clients
events, business lunches.
You need to figure out
how to live in your food
freedom, which may or may
not include these food going
forward.
So don't schedule
around-- you'll
never find 40 days where
the only thing you're doing
is staying at home
watching Netflix.
That's not going to happen.
So make sure it's nothing
that's so special you
wouldn't want to miss it.
But I would include
some of those every day,
but still specialish
occurrences.
And then figure out
how to make it work.
Right?
You're ordering a
sparkling water with lime.
And you're just as festive,
and you're just as cheersing.
And it's just as
happy in that hour.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
MELISSA HARTWIG:
Yeah, thank you.
AUDIENCE: 3 and 1/2 years
and counting and loving
it, loving every minute of it.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Cool.
AUDIENCE: I have
one situation that
continues to be challenging,
which is at this point,
pretty much everyone in my life
knows that I have eating habits
that they might consider
quirky or bizarre
or against conventional
wisdom or whatever it is.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Occasionally,
I'm a guest
in someone's house,
which happened actually
this weekend, where, oh,
you can eat everything.
It's all gluten free and full of
honey and artificial sweeteners
and rice flour and all kinds of
things that I'm not going near.
How do you prepare for-- well,
I know how I prepare internally.
But how do you prepare
socially for those situations
and handle those with
a well-meaning host who
is actually going against
everything that you want?
MELISSA HARTWIG: I
totally get that.
And I had that situation
at the holidays
this past year
where I was served
pasta full of ricotta cheese
and I was like, oh, this
is going to be tough.
Are you on the Whole30
during this situation?
Or is this just part
of your food freedom?
AUDIENCE: I'm not.
MELISSA HARTWIG: OK, so
you're not on the Whole30.
So this is one of
those situations where
you have to weigh sticking to
your preferences versus really
hurting someone's feelings.
Ideally, you're having
a conversation ahead
of time, if at all possible.
Hey, I just want
to let you know.
Just like if you were a
vegetarian, for example.
I just want to let
you know that I
don't eat this, this, and this.
If that's going to be a
problem with your menu,
I'd be happy to bring a dish.
Let me know what I
could contribute.
When you get there, if they've
gone out of the way and said,
this is all gluten-free, but
it's full of this other stuff,
then it comes down to, how bad
is it going to mess you up.
If it's going to
seriously mess you up
with migraines or
headaches or asthma
or whatever, then you have
to politely decline, and say,
you know what, I
really would love to.
And I'm so, so thankful that you
took the time to prepare this.
But I really have a bad reaction
with artificial sweeteners.
And if I eat it, this
is going to happen.
So I'll politely decline,
but thank you so much.
If it's just a preference,
then you have to think about,
I might just take
one for the team.
And eat as little as
possible to be polite.
Share with someone else.
Pass your plate on
to someone else.
Take a bite or two and
say, this was amazing.
Thank you so much.
But I'm saving for
the next course
if you know it's more edible.
But this is where
you have to weigh
hurting someone's feelings and
being gracious against what
is really just a preference
and not an actual sensitivity.
So I ate three bites of
this pasta with ricotta.
And I knew the dairy
was going to kill me.
I spent the rest of the
night not feeling well.
But it was the
woman I didn't know.
I didn't have any
opportunity to communicate.
I ate a couple bites.
I passed it along
and said, I'm really
saving for the
next course, which
I knew I could totally eat.
And I sucked it up and took it.
And so sometimes you
just have to decide
what's worth it for you.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: My wife
doesn't eat eggs.
And I was wondering what
kind of interesting options
for breakfasts that you
do during the Whole30.
MELISSA HARTWIG: I
love that question.
We get that question
all the time.
In fact, in the
"Whole30" book, there's
a whole intro about what you can
eat for breakfast if you're not
eating eggs.
So first of all,
I really encourage
people to get that idea of
breakfast, lunch, dinner
out of your head.
We just call them Meal
1, Meal 2, and Meal 3.
And for Meal 1, I'm just
as likely to have a burger
as I am to have an omelet.
The other morning,
I literally cooked
a burger for Megan and I.
That was our breakfast.
And it was amazing.
So you can have absolutely
anything you want,
leftovers for breakfast,
or cook any kind of protein
that you want.
But if you want more
of a breakfasty feel,
we do have some
really good recipes.
So think things like
ground chicken and apples
and sweet potato and
a few diced walnuts
with a little apple cider
vinegar, a warm hash style.
Sausage, whether
it's pork sausage,
ideally pastured and organic,
or some kind of chicken sausage
would be a good choice.
Soups in the morning are good.
I also love a good
breakfast salad,
which I know sounds weird.
But I got into the
habit of eating
salad first thing in the morning
when I was in Scandinavia,
and just fell in
love with the idea.
So maybe breakfast salads
with some sort of protein
on top that just feel different,
so almost so different
that it's cool that you're
eating it for breakfast.
But there are a lot.
If you just Google Whole30
egg-free breakfasts,
you will come up with a
million different ideas
from our community.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Yeah, yeah.
STACEY SASAKI: Are there
any other questions
from the audience?
If not, that gives us a
perfect time for you guys
to get the books, get
some signing done.
And we want to thank you
so much for being here.
MELISSA HARTWIG: Thank
you all for having me.
This was really fun.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]